okay guys we're back I got salmon you
know I'm not I'm not ashamed to admit it
I cook some salmon and I'll be eating at
Doris one okay so we just tell people I
got salmon you know maybe they might
like it and now I used two different
cuts of salmon so I don't know Colonel
said okay salmon we go I'll be Obama cow
eyes don't wear a PMA hmm okay let's say
what I got let's do what I got perfect
huh okay ha [ __ ] ha ha ha ha
okay well [ __ ] hot burning my [ __ ]
up but so good yeah you are a yes
they're Republican I have one medium
shot
we have a against me you the public end
come on oh yeah come on God come on yeah
yeah yeah
look please don't kill me
oh I [ __ ] up I took two packets like
one packet was the same when the other
one was like fish but I thought was say
I went to it I just say it like cottage
sand mixed together sucked out
yes I lived
see look at all those are that a lack of
health care so sad look out talk to that
okay the baby a baby yeah oh yeah I'm
going for a okay baby
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
I got on the bottom right away
Oh
if you don't want for a okay you are
Rapala him [ __ ] oh we don't [ __ ] kill
me
[ __ ] I don't know if I going to make it
through this night yeah
I don't know [ __ ] long-ass nine-second
long as my intention
I'm in love with a ripper baby yeah yeah
yeah
oh yeah yeah
oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's a [ __ ] everyone [ __ ]
spamming a [ __ ] I'll report dead meat
right now where is it where is it I get
that isn't my thanks I'll fire
I'm in love with mr. Bailey yeah yeah
yeah yeah
hello with a ripper baby yeah yeah yeah
yeah Oh better yeah yeah yeah yeah oh
[ __ ]
I'm loud with a ripper baby yeah yeah
yeah oh [ __ ]
Oh repealed Oh
oh yeah you like that I like that that I
you like that you like that Pathak oh
[ __ ] I just [ __ ] them I just [ __ ]
them all oh [ __ ]
I'm killing a bit sunbae
hell I got paper where I get [ __ ]
destroy them we're gonna - China
we're going to get this batch
here we go really yeah yeah yeah now
what else I got at the end here oh my
god they can't kill a butterfly camera I
think I've actually Lynch a butterfly it
[ __ ] up oh they turn them back into
Martha very sad
the best defenses you say the other
gesture and we just like in wreck them
there can be two gestures someone
texting so these people that are fall
I'm a you're either like a [ __ ]
instigate which is a random person
okay done okay
[ __ ] ap didn't vote for me I can't do
any more if I say I say I thought it
uses the kills one person every single
day
- [ __ ] he live in a [ __ ] crash Bob
oh happy also [ __ ] do I win
I honestly don't know what's a jesters
off
uh-huh chat lag disgusting and so anti
disgusting
okay gotta go bye-bye okay gotta go
Sarah [ __ ] anyone here like burritos
that's what I was now
shut do I get the [ __ ] kill better
gotta taste great a little for money
yeah pale about my bed I throw you Lazar
how about I throw this arrow and you won
like chicken or Oh a hammer a bad man I
am holy [ __ ]
[ __ ] hike yes dad kick it okay thank
a whole lotta back out